everyone has that thing or they point
back to and go that's when I realized
this is a problem worth solving what was
yours mine was when I experienced
identity theft so I pulled my credit
reports and the scarier part was not the
identity theft of these accounts people
opened it was the accounts that I opened
for all these student loans and I had
never actually looked at the numbers I
just knew like well we'll get student
loans and eventually I'll have to deal
with them I had it up exactly what I
owed in all these student loans and it
took my breath away
and then I realized my first job out of
college
it was barely enough to pay rent the
student loan minimum payments because
you actually have to pay those back once
you graduate all of my utility bills and
I was like this is the path that I was
sold this is it and that is when I was
like this something's got to give
because this sucks this life is terrible
and I was super cynical towards
adulthood toward all the lies that
people had told me and then I realized
oh okay it's not all my fault but it's
my responsibility